그 맥가 대비했을 때 대출 비율이
높은 그런 건물들은 아무래도
매도인이 좀
급하다고 생각할 수 있겠죠
[음악]
어저께 저희 그
매입했던 고객분한테 이제 연락이
왔어요 지금 현금
쌓아 놓고 있으니까
괜찮은 거 있으면
꼭 연락 달라고 최근에 좀
고객분들한테 그런 연락들이 많이 오는
거 같아요
급매 나온 거 없냐 아무래도
빌딩을 한번 투자하셨던 분들이
아무래도이 시장에 대한 확신이 좀
있기 때문에 그런 것 때문에 좀
연락을 많이 주시는 거 같아요 제가
오늘은
강남
급매 빌딩 매입하는 방법을 주제로
촬영을 하도록 하겠습니다 뭐 강남
같은 경우에는
그래도 다른 지역보다는 뭐 지금같이
고금리 시대에도 좀 타격이나 이런 건
좀 덜 한 거 같아요 그리고
기존에 저희가 IMF 때나 리먼
때보다는
그래도
체력이 좀 돼 있는 상태고 저는
괜찮은게
그래도
작년 재작년보다는 더 나올 것
같습니다 그거는 뭐 기정사실입니다
저는 올해 상반기가 되게 많이 안
좋을 것 같아요 뭐 제롬 파일이 계속
이제 매파적인 계산을 하고 있지만
어느 정도 이제 조금 스탑 되고 조금
내려갈 기미가 보였을 때 그때 이제
거래량이 좀 그래도 폭발할 것 같은
느낌인데 아무래도 그때까지는 거래량이
그렇게 많지는 않을 것 같습니다
그래서 아무래도
견디지 못한 빌딩들이 좀 나올 것
같은데 그 중에 강남빌딩도 괜찮은게
좀 올해는 나오지 않을까네 그래서
현금을 가지고
계신 분은 오히려 좀 더
기회가 될 수 있는 그런 해일 것
같아요 사실 급매라고 해서 막 내가
산 금액 대비해서 막 몇십프로
저렴하게 뭐 이렇게 나올 것 같진
않은데
그래도 호가 보다는 좀 많이 조정이
돼서 나오지 않을까 그렇게 예상을
합니다 일단은 저희가 건물을 왜
나오는지를 일단 좀 판단을 해야 돼요
뭐 여러가지 이유가 있겠죠 뭐 상속
문제도 있고 그 다음에 이제 뭐 잔여
문제 자녀가 이제 사고 친다든지 뭐
그런 문제들도 있고
기타 등등 되게
여러 가지 이유가 있습니다 매물
나오는데
요즘 같은 시기에는 제 생각에는 두
가지가 가장 큰 거 같아요
우선 첫 번째로는
금리가 높아져서 1년 전보다 거의 한
2배 놀랐어요이자 감당이 안 돼서
나오는 매물 그리고 두 번째는 사업의
문제가 생긴 겁니다 너무 사업도
경기가 안 좋잖아요
돈이 아무래도 되게 말라 있기 때문에
사업이 안 되는 경우도 있거든요
그래서 제가 봤을 때 지금 같은
시장에는 두 가지 이유가 가장 큰 거
같아요 두 가지 이유로
시장에 나온 매물이
급메일 확률이 제가 봤을 때 높습니다
그래서 여러분들이 두 가지를 확인을
하셔야 되는데 우선 첫 번째는 대출이
많은 대출은 사실
등기사항 전부 증명서
등기부등본을 떼면은 대출이 얼마 나와
있는지 나와 있습니다 그 맥가
대비했을 때 대출 비율이 높은 그런
건물들은 아무래도
매도인이 좀
급하다고 생각할 수 있겠죠 대출
금액이 높으니까 그리고
최근에 대출을 많이 받은
기존의 매입할 때 받고
추가적으로 계속 대출받은 그런
건물들도 있거든요 그래서 그런 것들은
돈이 없는 거예요 그리고 최근에
매물 나왔던 것도 제가 등기상
전문점에서 보니까 이제 7명에서
봤다가 1금융에서 안 나오니까
대부업체를
써서 빌렸더라고요 그리고 만약에 개인
이름으로 돼 있다 이런 경우에는
사체일 경우도 되게 높거든요 만약에
내가 a라는 건물을 검토 중이다라고
하면은
등기사항 전문 증명서를 꼭 미리 떼서
보세요이 사람이 뭐 때문에 파는지
지금 급한 상황인지 아닌지 그래서이
사람이 급한 상황이면 아무래도 뭐
계약 조건이라든지 이런 걸 되게 좀
유리하게 할 수 있겠죠 그리고 두
번째로는 사업이 잘못된 거예요 그분의
사실
옛날부터 그냥 대출 없이 오래전부터
가지고 계셨던 분은 지금
크게 영향이 없어요 이분은 뭐 대출도
없고 그냥 강 넘어서 불구경하는
거에요 지금 계속 예전부터 가지고
계셨던 분 그분들 매물이 나오긴 쉽진
않습니다
근데 내가 대출이 많거나 사업이
잘못된 거야 내가 하는 사업이 그래서
여러분들이
뭔가 협상을 이끌어 내려면 일단 뭐
하시는 분인지도 확인 가능하면 좋고
그리고 그 기업 예를 들어서 뭐
법인명으로 되어 있다라고 하면은
인터넷에 검색하면 뭐 그 기업
정보라든지 위로 결제하면은 좀
세부적인 것까지 볼 수 있어요 그래서
최근에 본 업체도
매출이 좀 계속 좋다가
2021년에 좀 많이 안 좋아진
거예요 그렇게 법인명의로 되어
있다라고 하면은 그 법인에 조금
히스토리를 좀 보실 필요가 있습니다
근데 그 법인면 중에이 부동산을 사기
위해서 설립한 법인들이 있어요 이제
막 세운 법인들 그래서 그런 법인들은
뭐 재무제표나 이런 실적들이 없기
때문에 제가 봤을 때 매도인이 좀
상황이 안 좋을 확률이 좀 높겠죠
기존에 뭐 재무제표 괜찮은 법인보다
그런 거라든지 그 법인이 언제
설립했는지 모하는 법인인지 지금
상황은 어떤지까지도
확인하면 좋습니다 어찌됐든 상대를
알아야 뭔가 뭔가 협상을 할 수
있잖아요 그래서 제가 봤을 때 지금
여러분들이 강남에 좀 괜찮은 건물은
살 수 있는 뭔가 기회가
왔는데 그런 기회를 포착할 수 있는
거는 두 가지
첫 번째는 대출금 두 번째로는 그
사업이 안 돼서요 두 분류가 조금
급매일 확률이 되게 좀 높지 않나
여러분들이 또 마지막으로
해야 될 거는 중개사의 역할을 되게
중요한 것 같아요 중개사 사실
작년이나 뭐 제작년
2021년이 피크였는데 그때는
매도인한테 연락하면은 너무
협상이 안 돼요
전화해도 선생님 뭐
금액 조금 조정해 주면 하실 것
같은데요 전화 끊어 막 전화도 안
받고 그런게 되게 많았는데 만약에 그
매도인이 꼭 팔아야 되는 상황이다라고
하면은요 중개사의 역할에 따라서
조건이 좀 많이 달라지는 것 같아요이
중개사를 잘 어떻게 보면 이용해서
협상을 하신다면 이런 시기에 좀
괜찮은 매물을
매입할 수 있지 않을까 그런 생각을
했습니다 올해 이제 매물을 보면은
외곽에 괜찮은 건물들이 계속 눈에 띌
거예요 오 뭐 저렇게 깔끔하고 저런
임차인이 들어가 있는 건물이이
가격이야 뭐 이런 경우가 되게 많을
거거든요
근데
진짜 뭐 제가 당부드리고 싶은 거는
그런 거 사면 안 됩니다 지금 오히려
더 강남권의 아니면 주요 지역에 있는
빌딩을 사야 돼요 오히려 기회예요
그런데 살 수 있는
근데
계속 외곽 거를 계속 투자해요 막
그러니까 이제 뭐 임대료라든지 뭐
임차인이라든지 이런게 좋아서 계속
외곽으로 투자를 하는데
진짜 저는 완전 비추입니다 무조건
주요 지역에 안전한데 사야 됩니다 뭐
항상 하는 얘기지만
물고기가 있는데 낚싯대는 넣어야지
물고기가 잡힙니다 여러분들 진짜
수만가지 유혹이 있을 거야 아마 막
외곽에
계속 좋은 매물을 보고 하면은 아
외곽에 투자하는 해야 되나 막 이런
생각을 하게 되는데
절대 유혹에 넘어가지 마시고
강남 지역에
투자를 하시기 바랍니다 그게 나중에
5년 뒤 10년 뒤 봤을 때는
정말 잘한 선택이라고 생각하실 거예요
가격 오르는 폭도 다를 겁니다
지금 같이 고금리 시대에는 대출을
많이 받으시면 안 돼요 뭐 예전에는
금리가 낮다 보니까 좀 레버리지를 잘
이용해서 투자하는 거를 좀
말씀드렸는데
요즘같이 고금리 시대에는 대출을
최대한 받으시면 안 돼요 그래서 진짜
현금이 한 50% 이상 있어야 됩니다
그 총 매매가에
그래야지 나중에 버틸 수도 있고
지금 뭐 시장 사항이나 이런 것
때문에 되게 좀 불안할 수도 있는데
저희가 돌이켜 생각해보면
IMF 때나 리먼떼 그때 뭐라도
샀으면 나중에 후회하잖아요 지금도
뭔가
기회인 거를 조금 포착하면은 그리고
나중에 뭐 5년 20년 뒤에 좀 그런
수익을
얻을 수 있지 않을까 이렇게 생각을
하는데 제가 말씀드린 기준을 좀
부합하는 거를 사셨으면 좋겠습니다